bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got no
wreck here thank you so much for doing
this sir
thank you happy to be here absolutely
let's just jump right into
your background where did you grow up
what did you do before you got into a
bitcoin cryptocurrencies
yeah i was born in urban armenia
i studied for engineering started with
my career
as an engineer never ended up being a
good engineer i quit my work after two
years
started an agency and then grown that
agency to provide engineering services
to startups from us mainly etc
and yeah obviously like like anyone we
were trying our own ideas products etc
then 2017 came in it was january it was
i think june then we i started
investing into cryptocurrencies and
caught myself manually calculating 10
times a day how much i own
i figured there needs to be an app
basically
to to show how much you you own
and we quickly called it the ah because
we already had a team etc
on app store and it appeared that
thousands of other people needed that
kind of an app too
and then the bull market happened it
grown
then we figured out we need to sync
automatically with exchanges because
it's not really
handy to manually enter your
transactions then we figured out you
need
to sync wallets then we figure out you
need to sync
other platforms then d5 came in
uh you basically using those smart
contracts to show your liquidity on
unislab or or
or or things like landing on your other
and all other kind of defy tracking and
management stuff
absolutely and so when you think about
coin stats today
maybe let's just walk through kind of
what the actual product
does so uh most users they have uh
cryptocurrency assets
all over the place uh they've got you
know different exchanges for different
reasons they may have something in
a wallet hardware software whatever walk
through kind of just like
what you guys have built and how it
actually works
yeah exactly i mean it's even
recommended to do so to
distribute your holdings into multiple
places uh they do that for security
reasons
also for accessing the certain
opportunities quickly you should keep
some
some of your funds on exchange so when
the prices move you have a quick action
to basically sell it or buy more etc so
that leads to problem you get lost on
what you own where you own how much
you've made how much you've lost
and also it creates a problem you should
log into each platform to see your
holdings to trade
you you you need 10 different apps on
your phone and 10 different bookmarks
website
on your on your computer so what
questions does it consolidate
all of your holdings into into one place
and it's being done automatically with
five to ten minutes set up
and you you have everything in one place
and as soon as
our customers do it they they completely
fell in love with it
they feel the magic and they they can't
stop coincidence because
uh i mean obviously the entering your
trades transactions into some
spreadsheets or some apps
is like like past stage no no no one
should do that
uh you should you should better
automatically sync
and down you have all your data in one
place and you can
not only track your data but also
trade from from coin stats uh
in fact we are going to expand our
trading ability and financial management
ability not only trade in the future but
also access
i don't know uh maybe land money from
from smart contract ave
or compound or or anything else so
so the the end goal is really to become
an interface to crypto that's how we
call ourselves
meaning an easy to use front end
or interface to all kind of different
crypto products
and uh smart contracts
or exchanges while at anything it can be
we are even comparing ourselves to the
browsers
in early 90s or 95 96 but
browser is just an interface to to
internet right so absolutely and so when
you think through this
uh you have a consumer-facing technology
uh
obviously you have grown really really
fast over the last couple of months
talk a little bit about what you're
seeing in the trends of the growth right
so where are people coming from what are
they doing on the platform
uh and kind of from an aggregate growth
standpoint how quickly is everything
growing
yeah sounds good we have grown to over
800 000 mentally monthly active unique
users
over the last three months uh mainly
uh we acquire users through word of
mouth
so our main acquisition channels channel
is
people searching coin stats on all kinds
of search networks be that google search
or app store etc
that's the main channel because people
are using us people recommend to
their friends and they start searching
price ads on app stores etc
and uh and obviously we have seen huge
growth recently because of market type
because
of a lot of people started investing
into cryptocurrencies
and market trends nowadays even make you
use so many different products and
wallets and exchanges
all kind of stuff because i mean you
need to buy this coin it's on uni stuff
you should use metamask then buying a
smart chain comes in you should use
finest smart chain to to use this to to
to invest on this coin and
uh there are so many products c5 c5
products like
celsius nexo we think all to all of them
block five
and uh basically i think one of the main
reasons people
use us and they've seen huge growth is
us being on top of the market and
integrating the
platforms people are using like finance
marketing growing recently really fast
it took us a week to implement buying a
smart chain and a blog file gets a lot
of users we integrate block file because
our
customers need that all of our
competitors
are very very slow on on that thing
integrations with new platforms etc d5
speak
we have a lot of features around defy
you can track your liquidity on unislab
as soon as you connect your ethereum
wallet
and uh that also leads to
one of the most exciting things we are
working on right now is allowing trading
on on d5
in next couple of months absolutely
and so when you think through the
decentralized finance how does that
change when you onboard
uh decentralized finance uh versus let's
say a centralized service like a block
fi
right like what are the technical uh
complexities
uh or is it actually less friction uh to
interface with d5 applications versus
centralized applications
uh that's that's a great question i
think uh one and one uh
the the centralized deep fight
centralized financial platforms like
block fi have one big advantage their
teams
are are consumer focused they can do
great uis
great user experience they can do great
marketing advertisement
and onboard those customers with easy to
use interface etc
the teams who are very talented on a
part of blockchain finance economy
or creating those really tough to create
smart contracts
uh or don't have good experience or
don't focus on user experience like try
to put
any of your friend out of crypto to use
other he'll get lost i mean even if
if he spends eight hours on that that's
really hard to use
that's not bad that's just because our
team is talented
on smart contracts rather than user
interface that's exactly what we want to
solve we want to take the
the smart contract they created and
offer
that solution with the same easiness of
use
as block fi or any other centralized
financial service provider
company and advertise it the same way as
block by advertising so
uh and and obviously uh the thing that
defy has
much more advantage over t5 i'm talking
about the
differences uh i i have an opinion that
cifi
won't make sense at all that won't work
out if d5 doesn't work out
because if d5 doesn't work out nobody
won't would want
to invest into ethereum or those coins
if nobody
buys ethereum nobody would use c5
absolutely and so when you think through
this um
are people using the product because
they want to
trade they want to just be informed
about what their portfolio and other
assets are doing
like what do you find is that the hook
or the thing that's really driving a lot
of the activity because 800 000
monthly active users is a really big
number uh what's driving those people
again i think it's uh driving the
ability to see
how much they are i mean that's the main
pain point how much i own now
i mean the market is up 20 today down 20
tomorrow right how much i own what's my
net worth
and the second value we give is your
profit loss how much you have made on
your last rate
you have four profit loss options like
last rate current holdings all time on
each of the coin you invested in
and we get all your transactions from
those exchanges automatically
even if you're using binance binos has
no ui for
easily checking the price you bought
your bitcoin for
they they show just tables etc you can
you can basically
export to spreadsheet manually check it
out uh
i think uh the number of connections
we have with the ability to to sync to
and ability to see how much you own and
i think
we have grown mostly because the market
has grown to state
then the product market feeds of our
product
have become became even stronger because
people are using so many different
platforms
in back in 2018 it was only a couple of
exchanges like people are bank on
coinbase etc
right now people don't stop buying
bitcoin on coinbase they won't
just defy coins because those defy coins
are the ones who do 10x of 20x
and those defy coins are not accessible
to to a lot of people because
it's it's hard to buy them it's hard to
use unislav
you need to understand metamask you need
to install
connect transaction approve it then the
swap evade you don't understand if it
worked out or not
that's why we want to just just make it
easier
and we want the same buy bitcoin
experience as you see on coinbase or any
other
similar product but you can buy any coin
which is trading on default
and again obviously 90 percent of
those defy coins won't do good on a long
term because those
startups they will fail but those are
the investment opportunities which can
potentially do thousand xs
because you can potentially invest on
make next facebook
next apple next tesla because they're
they're there
no no consumer
in the history of human had an
opportunity to invest like
in in facebook when it was 10 million
valuation like no no one had opportunity
right even if they bought it
they couldn't right now we are living in
in a world
where almost everyone can can invest on
next facebook
because i'm almost sure the next
facebook some decentralized social
network idea
is trading somewhere on unislab along
those
ten thousand other coins trading on
unisa i mean it's a lot of work to
research to find the euro
who is going to be next facebook uh but
but it's there
or or the next netflix decentralized
streaming platform or the next i don't
know amazon
it's a nice shopping platform etc
yeah so you basically um have sit in a
very interesting spot right one is
obviously coin stats and the product you
guys have built and the large user base
you have
but also you grew up outside the united
states right you were born in armenia
and uh maybe talk a little bit about
like
what is going on in that country
specifically and then what you see from
the international user base versus
anyone in the united states
uh that's that's a great question uh
in armenia and all of the similar
countries central banks
are really afraid of bitcoin because
they are lazy
to try out new stuff they don't want
changes because they work for government
for central bank they
hate changes it's stable it works why we
need bitcoin etc
and uh but if
they've worked hard researched hard and
he gave the opportunity
to people invest in bitcoin or access
those
investment opportunities and obviously
by by training them teaching them that
there is a risk involved invest
money you can afford to use etc uh that
would have been great but unfortunately
armenian
governments central banks and any other
central bank
in developing countries doesn't do that
for for for
their people and what
other than that what i like about
blockchain decentralized
sphere decentralization and this their
exchanges trading etc
the startups the companies are
decentralized in the world
too like in other series most of the
startups are silicon valley
in crypto it's all over the world i mean
europe asia u.s etc and
startups from asia market for u.s
companies from u.s
markets for market for consumers from
asia et cetera so decentralized that
also creates new opportunities for
entrepreneurs from other countries in
developing countries who
who are not in silicon valley don't have
funds accessible funds easy to
easy to access investments and networks
to create their own startups which can
become
big in in next years uh
so that's that's what i really like
about this this crypto space because it
creates also so many new opportunities
in any case it creates so many
new opportunities because it's it's
revolution again i mean it's
it's going to be big in if
i would i recommend every engineer out
there to start
learning solidity and smart contracts
etc
because they're gonna be the ones who
get paid the most
in next two years or two years or ten
years
yeah and it feels also like there's this
uh this huge advantage that you have
in terms of uh anyone in the world now
who takes on and
learns uh computer science skills and
can code
uh can use an internet connection they
can create any a product
in the software uh realm and then they
can release it to the world and they can
put it on a global stage almost
immediately and so
um those software developers also need
to build teams and so whether you know
marketing or operations or customer
service or any other kind of
non-technical skill
you can team up with these software
developers and build a company and build
a product and
really kind of scale these and make them
successful and i think that what you're
describing here is essentially the
promise of the internet
right is that anyone with that internet
connection can tap into this kind of
open decentralized protocol
and they can participate in the global
economy uh which ultimately is what
is creating and capturing so much value
as this plays out right
yeah yeah exactly and crypto space
also creates new opportunities i mean
it's very tough to create
a new dating website or new social
network website
uh sitting somewhere in armenia because
there's so much competition going on
but if you create decentralized dating
or decentralized
social network at least you'll have
early adopters
in face of those crypto enthusiasts
crypto community
who would love to use it to trade out
and if it's good it they will continue
to use it it will grow over with the
crypto market etc
absolutely what's been the biggest
surprise for you over the last three or
four months as all this growth has
occurred
uh i think that that's a great question
let me think
i mean obviously bitcoin reaching 50 000
so early
that's that's a great surprise and
i'm very surprised about the latest
growth
like last week of buying a smart chain
uh because i mean
it took almost all the volume from
unislap i mean it has comparable
volume the pancake swapping has
comparable volume to
to unislap i'm surprised about it and
uh i will continue to look at it further
etc
again we can talk about how
decentralized it it is etc i'm pro
decentralization
uh so ethereum is obviously more
decentralized uh let me think of a third
thing that surprised me
surprised me the most uh
of yeah i have great stat the
out of all ethereum wallets connected to
coin stats over hundred thousand
right just a lot of different kind of
people connecting their ethereal values
to coin stats
35 of them have some liquidity of
unislap
35 that's a lot
a hundred thousand ethereum wallets that
are connected to coin stats
35 of them have some level of liquidity
with unesco
exactly wow that's a crazy statistic
yeah i was surprised i i was expecting
one two maybe
ten but it's 35. yeah that is nuts
talk a little bit about um kind of your
future plans right so what are you guys
looking to incorporate into coin stats
and then
kind of how do you see uh things like
binance smart chain or others uh in
terms of
how that affects your product road map
uh that's that's a great question i
think uh
the short term goal for us to come up
with the defy trading
easy to use swaps of coins
underneath which will run on on
blockchain be that spina smart chain
ethereum or any other
that that's that's good for that right
and
uh we also working on our wallet which
would
run those trades also you can use if you
don't want to use coins as well you can
use metamouse trust or
whatever wallet you're using currently
and as soon as trading works out
we'll prove that our idea of becoming
the front end of
blockchain uh is good and we would start
integrating
other financial services which currently
work on
popular on on smart contracts on
blockchain
either landing platforms or or anything
else
because like i i was looking at
urine finance right now you can earn 20
yearly interest on your diet stable coin
there's no no risk there there's no
bitcoin etc which can go down to 10 000
et cetera diet and i mean
that you you won't get that interest
rate on any other bank
in the world on on dollars
and if someone can make that accessible
with a click of a button to all over the
world that's that's down
uh that's that's and earn i don't know
point one percent fee
or point zero one percent fee that's
that's
a great sort of idea i mean i do
understand that it
involves a lot of regulation
complications a lot of trust
complications
we both understand that we trust smart
contracts right
try to explain that to to a person who
have saved
his hundred thousand dollars
over the last 20 years and he wants to
earn interest on that try to explain
that i mean
that's complicated but i'm sure we'll
get there
and i think banks especially small banks
innovative banks should
work with crypto blockchain etc
and offer those solutions to their
customers because
uh consumers trust banks right i mean
they they put all of their money into
banks etc
banks can utilize
smart contracts defy on
on earning more interest for their
consumers they'll be
going they'll be doing good and i see no
reason for that not happening right i
mean why it won't happen it's just a
matter of time and
technology some more uh security to be
added and development
time marketing it takes time it doesn't
have an immunity but it will happen over
the next couple of years i'm sure
and we want to be there when it happens
and we want to be part of that market
too
yeah i i tend to uh to agree with you
there my friend
um what are the things that you're
looking for as we move forward in terms
of milestones
for the bitcoin and crypto market are
there specific things that you're saying
hey this hasn't happened yet but i'm
looking forward to when it happens i
think that'll be the next inflection
point
uh that's that's a tough question i
think
the eth2 version is
going to change a lot in the markets
because one reason those kind of
solutions aren't in humane market aren't
into main market yet because of ethereum
gases etcetera mining
uh and if you get there if it's
on main net 100 if it works that's gonna
be big
with all of those competitors polka dot
cordano buying a smart chain etc
right now let's face the truth ethereum
owns 99.9
of all the market and if they they
they could and it's decentralized
because it used to be proof of work and
it's proof of work right now
and and through proof-of-stake
decentralization comes only when it's
come
it comes from proof of work so it
worked mining it said for computers
video cards it's hard and
when it comes in i think that will
change a lot you know
in in the in a it will space because
it's going to be more easier to use with
all of those
minuses the human blockchain has higher
gas fees
it's number one i mean it has the same
level of
uh volume you only swap social swap
things as coinbase the number one
the exchange was doing ipo right now or
thinking to do
and yeah i'm looking at that and some
people ask when
ethereum price would reach ten thousand
dollars no way it can reach ten thousand
dollars before
that release because no one would
continue use unislop and it reaches to
ten thousand because
for each sub you'd pay thousand dollars
i mean that's
that's an awesome no one would pay
thousand dollars for swapping one coin
to another
even if they're swapping 100k so
so but it can easily reach 10 000
obviously then
ethereum's 2.0 releases etc so i'm very
much looking at that
and obviously bitcoin halving we have
seen it's a traffic
bitcoin is uh something
that limited and
history shows that it always goes up no
matter what
and i don't see a reason for it to stop
going up there's no reason i mean the
only reason can be us government
banning bitcoin like whoever uses
bitcoin goes to jail
but that's obviously we know that that
won't happen
and and yeah bitcoin prices will grow i
think on the long term it can go
10 000 tomorrow at the long term it will
be good
ethereum economy is complicated
because ethereum can be number one
blockchain in the world
everyone might use ethereum but not
necessary ethereum would be very
expensive
that's complicated economy so so yeah
that's
what i feel about this market right now
yeah absolutely uh before we uh we wrap
up i want to do
um rapid fire questions but uh where can
people find uh coin stats if they want
to go and
try the product they want to join the
800 000 people are using it every month
where do you send people uh
just just go on any search network and
search coin stats
uh be that on app store google play
even mac os store even tv os store
etc we are available on on
desktop you can use as a website you can
use as an app it's
so it's uh accessible on all of your
devices
and i think we also have the promo code
pump which gives you if i'm not
taking 20 or 30 off on our
class you can try it for free get the
trial on
see the magic feel the magic and start
using it
uh you can use it for free if you
connect up to two counts
and then uh you can use the pump codes
to get pro or premium if you want to
connect more than 10.
got it it makes a makes a lot of sense
so people go to just search
coin stats uh on google or in any of the
app stores and then there's a free
version but if you want to use any of
the premium
plans you can just use code pop and you
can discount there
uh i got three questions then you get to
ask me one to finish up first question
is what's the most important book you've
ever read
um that's a great question i mean that's
tough to do was the most important book
if you are talking about startup etc
i like a book called traction i think
eric rice
which talks about all the marketing
channels how you can grow the the
product i think that the same person
wrote
the book leave startup which is also
good so you can
how you build the company in elimbe how
to grow it in a lean way
and traction talks more about the
marketing channels and how
to do right marketing for your product
that the main message is just choose
one marketing channel and push
hard for that until some level of your
product then choose the second one then
choose third one so just just push
on on just single marketing channel at
the time if you're a style
absolutely uh second question is more
personal uh
sleep schedule this comes from our
friends over at eight sleep
uh i sleep on their thermoregulated bed
it is amazing i turn it
cold as hell and basically sleep on an
ice cube
uh and now rather than sleep six hours i
sleep like eight or nine
what is your sleep schedule and how has
that evolved over the years
yeah it seems you don't have kids so we
i have i have two two kids so sleep
schedule is
is usually depends on their sleep
schedule
so so yeah but by most of the time i
sleep eight nine hours a day it's fine i
don't have any
unfortunately any sleep food problems so
and i can sleep anywhere i like to
eat that uh without just uncomfortable
sofa or anything
so so yeah i don't it's great i love it
uh last question and you get to ask me
one is aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
of course i mean i mean
there is no probability there is very
small probability
i mean it's almost zero that there are
no aliens i mean
obviously there are aliens uh but the
thing is uh why they don't
contact us maybe because they're afraid
of those uh wilder aliens
who so yeah that's that but the universe
is so big there can be no
no no one else we can't be alone
i love that perspective of maybe they're
scared
that's great what uh what question do
you have for me to uh to wrap up
uh yeah i think i'd ask you a question
on on defy how do you think it will grow
and then do you think the the
uh regular financial corporations like
regular banks will start utilizing it
so my guess is that some banks are
already starting um
to do it and uh and we'll kind of see
how long it takes for them to really
really jump in
uh but they're kind of you know
experimenting they're testing it out
they're trying to understand it both
intellectually but also a little bit in
practice you know can they set up nodes
can they
uh participate um i think that the
biggest
thing is similar to bitcoin bitcoin d5
all this stuff it's just time
right it just takes time for people to
get educated it takes time for people to
learn
uh it takes time for people to get
comfortable using this stuff
but it's a foreground conclusion of
course the world is going to run on open
decentralized protocols right i think
that is literally
at this point a very obvious thing and
so
i just think people should be patient
right just chill out
relax and uh and all will be good in the
world uh
as more and more time uh kind of expires
i love that answer thank you
uh all right where can we send people to
find you on the internet if they want to
follow up or they get any questions for
you
uh just just go on twitter now right
gabor cam
i have very tough surname to typing uh
but if you go to the coins that's
twitter page you can can find ceo
uh twitter tag on on the description
and yeah again i forgot to say we are on
coinstats.app
so if you don't want to search on google
just go to coinstats.app
and you'll find coinstars all its great
features etc
amazing listen narek thank you so much
for uh for taking the time to do this
uh i think that it is a pretty
incredible you've built a product that's
got you know eight hundred thousand
monthly active users and growing very
quickly
uh so keep up the great work and we'll
have this again in the future
thank you thanks for having me and it
was great to talk to you